[Music]
coca-cola is the second most universally
understood term in the world just behind
okay 94% of the world's population
understand coca-cola there were only 33
non-alcoholic drinks that generate over
1 billion dollars in revenue coca-cola
owns 15 of Li coca-cola spent more money
on advertising than Microsoft and Apple
combined in 2010 they spent a whopping
2.9 billion on advertising coca-cola
manufactures so many different beverages
that if you drank one per day it would
take you over nine years to try all of
them and what's even more scary
in total they have about 3500 beverages
under their name across the globe
despite what you may have been told
coins or teeth won't dissolve in Coke
when left overnight it's a common
misconception at one time every glass of
coke contained about 9 milligrams of
cocaine however it was removed in 1903
years ago coca-cola launched an all-out
war on water the campaign was called
just say no to h2o in an attempt to get
people to order coke in restaurants
instead of free tap water the campaign
was quickly stopped once people started
to spread the news around it takes 2
liters of water to make one liter of
coca-cola and over 290 billion litres of
water are used to manufacture coke every
year around the world the inventor of
coca-cola who invented a drink in 1886
was heavily addicted to morphine he died
two years after the brand was launched
thanks for watching hit like below and
be sure to subscribe if you haven't
already let me know what you want me to
do in my future videos up in the comment
by
[Music]
you